the president will be in Florida today
stumping for Republican candidates ahead
of the midterm elections in November
at a White House news conference
yesterday with the Italian prime
minister president Trump renewed his
threat to shut down the government the
president also said he would be willing
to meet with Iran's president without
preconditions
we Jiang is at the White House we job
good morning good morning Alex president
Trump has asked for 25 billion dollars
for border security although he says
that's not a redline and he's open to
negotiation but he has appeared to draw
a deadline for reaching a deal before
the government faces a shutdown in
September the whole thing is ridiculous
and we have to change our laws president
Trump's message to Congress during a
press conference Monday was crystal
clear I would have no problem doing a
shutdown it's time we had proper border
security government funding runs out at
the end of September just weeks before
the midterm elections the last time the
President signed a short-term measure to
keep the government open it came with
the warning I say to Congress I will
never sign another bill like this again
I'm not gonna do it again
many Republicans doubt there's enough
time to pass an immigration bill and say
threatening a shutdown won't speed
things up if you're not willing to shut
the government down then it's probably
not a good tactic
to play President Trump also drew
criticism with remarks about meeting
with Iran's president Hassan rouhani
that you have recently ramped up their
hostile rhetoric they want to meet on me
anytime they want anytime they want it's
good for the country good for them good
for us and good for the world no
preconditions Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo said he was on board with a
meeting but contradicted the president
by saying Iran must make changes first
fundamental changes and how they treat
their own people reduced their malign
behavior can agree that it's worthwhile
to enter in a nuclear agreement that
actually prevents proliferation and the
president said and he's prepared to sit
down and have a conversation with him
iran's Foreign Minister says there are
no conditions for such a discussion
according to Iranian state TV and the
meeting is looking less likely because
the suspended economic sanctions Iran
was enjoying under the Iran nuclear deal
kicked back into place next week after
President Trump abandoned the deal in
May Nora all right we just thank you